[Music]
you've recently said that you've come to
terms with your own mortality
have you talked to your kids about
carrying on this Legacy and taking over
there anyway
most important to me is they're kind uh
empathetic
uh compassion
brilliant people well how could they not
Michael they are a product of you and
Tracy
and you are just that's Tracy small
Michael J fox though always funny is
very real at 61 he knows he won't live
to be 80. he's broken bones and
infection almost caused him to lose a
finger daily struggles include walking
and falling often
my feet
Michael's also not hiding the fact that
his tremors from Parkinson's have
progressed the answer is always my
biggest and my first response to
anything is what's funny about this and
sometimes it's
just looking for
enjoying things in his new documentary
still streaming tomorrow on Apple TV
plus Michael also details his struggle
with alcohol after his diagnosis which
he initially thought was a bad hangover
at 29. you haven't had a drink in 30
years but why did you want to open up
about this assassins this is part of
weight that we deal with it I mean I was
just I just was clearly using alcohol to
to to cover cover these I think there
are limitations with my size but there
aren't any limitations with the things I
want to do you know Mallory et's been
with Michael since the very beginning
watching the actor turn activist bring
awareness to the cause today the Michael
J fox Foundation has raised nearly two
billion dollars for Parkinson's Disease
research and his wife Tracy has been by
his side through it all can't wait to
see you love you could you imagine doing
life as anyone else other than oh no
Trace might be dead this July you'll
celebrate your 35th wedding anniversary
that's 25 years
foreign